to those who can overcome the obstacles
rise up when difficulties arise are the
ones who win the prize everybody starts
at the bottom and there is no advantage
to starting 10 years ago as a bloke
starting today in fact it's better today
than it was then action is determined by
your attitude and attitude is determined
by your path he's an American
businessman co-founder of M way and
owner of the Orlando Magic basketball
team at one point he was one of the 10
wealthiest Americans he has an estimated
net worth of 5.1 billion dollars he's
Rich DeVos and here's my take on his top
ten rules of success rule number five is
my personal favorite and I'd love to
know which one you guys liked about it
and as always guys if you hear something
that really resonates with you please
leave it down the comments below put
quotes around it as well so other people
can be inspired also when you write it
down you're much more likely to lock it
in for yourself as well
enjoy
you are a part of something that
transcends all the details of your
business it's a part of demonstrating
that free enterprise works that somebody
can start with a $50 sales kit and build
a large business you prove it every day
that it works and you prove it by
overcoming the obstacles that you have
to deal with there are all sorts of
people who want to break your faith some
time during your own family and some
time they're just so-called good friends
who think you're crazy for doing what
you're doing but you see you have
decided to take charge of your life you
have decided that you are going to
change you're not going to wait for the
government you're going to wait for some
school or something else to happen you
are going to change your situation
that's what free enterprise is all about
Jay and I decided to do that
I don't know over 50 60 years ago we
started in this kind of business in 1949
I was 23 all I know is this business I
shouldn't my life had been pretty good
but it wasn't always easy business isn't
life isn't but to those who can overcome
the obstacles rise up when difficulties
arise are the ones who win the prize I
recently picked up a book by a doctor
Norman Doidge do idge
he's a brain guy psychiatrist and he in
his study says that I can confirm to you
the power of positive thinking
scientifically because so many people
ridiculous ridicule that whole idea of
positive thinking exactly I can show you
positively that turning yourself into a
positive thinker will change your brain
and how it function
now you think about yourself and what
you can accomplish now it's been laughed
at and most of my life and you know that
that's just wishful thinking well I
don't think it's what she'll thinking
Norman didn't think it was special
thinking his was all biblically based
and Bob sure did pretty good with it I
did pretty good with starting at the
bottom anomaly is wherever you are today
everybody starts at the bottom and there
is no advantage to starting 10 years ago
as a bloke starting today in fact it's
better today than it was then our
products are better our line is better
our plan is better is more proving it's
a better plan today than when we started
and sometimes there are no answers as to
whether you want to be in business or
would like to be in business you you
just got to put your toe in the water
you know if you're going to wait till
you know everything you'll never do
anything then you always say well I got
check some more I'm into little more
research so go ahead just keep going and
you'll never get in a business you going
to go swimming you got to get what you
know and then you find the people of
that hot button for having a business of
their own and want to do their own thing
and like the chance to build a big
business well you got to have that dream
that's why the people talk about having
a dream all you got to have a little bit
of a dream and then you see I'll go and
get customers that you know I get a big
chance to build a really big thing I'm
the dog gets a customer when you start
something new it's not easy but life is
easier when you got a business in you're
making some money makes a little easier
so stick with it find our way through it
just find out an answer it works folks
this business works for those who work
it now I want to spend a little time on
a kind of an old subject and yet it's a
it's new in some ways but it deals with
the fear of failure that affects all of
us and I know you've come here with
hopes and faith in your future but back
there is a little bit of fear about
whether you can do
it or what somebody will say about you
sometimes we have people come to a
meeting like this who are even afraid to
tell their friends they came to an Amway
meeting for fear of what they will say
and so we are so driven by fear that
sometimes we never do anything because
we're fear of what somebody else will
say and what happens when you do that is
you give control of your life over to
someone else and then they decide what's
going to happen to you instead of you
decided now we have the fear of failure
the fear of what other people will say
the fear rejection the fear of change
now the first thing we must do is deal
with change and learn to accept the fact
that things are changing fast and so to
illustrate how to handle change I
thought since I hadn't been here in 8
years I would give you a little amway
history so you would see how we handled
change when Jay Van Andel and I started
our first business we started a flying
school now that was a change but the
important thing is that neither one of
us knew how to fly and so when you
consider doing something new you see oh
I can't do it I've never done this but
we didn't let our not flying stop us
from starting we just began and hired
instructors and learn from them but I
said what it finally comes down to in
your business and how you run it is you
first in me second take that home with
you you first and me second the first
thing you want to do is help your people
succeed and then you succeed just keep
it in the right order it's not you
succeeding and then hopefully they come
out okay it's all about them not about
you and I think that was the foundation
of our business you know we never say
and I never talked about how much money
we made or how much
we wanted to make we took a lot bigger
like ever business but it was never a
personal financial goal but our focus
was on how we could enrich the lives of
our people and make them better
oftentimes influencing them with our
faith as well my father was a very
positive guy you know you can do it you
can do it you can do it that was his his
mind and I was like you know people say
oh I can't do that he was the one who
said yes you can you wouldn't accept
from me a no or I can't do it
so you can actually he would get on me
higher law even saying it you know
thinking you can do it I graduated as
class president find me by her speak at
the commencement and he helped me put my
speech together it turned out three
pretty good one woman came up to me and
said you know you were a lot better than
a minister we had it was a class who is
our guest speaker that little phrase
that will experience really encouraged
me to keep that on a speaking side his
encouragement to me let me to build a
life around encouraging others and so I
so I've done attitude and action and
atmosphere you want to take the correct
action action is determined by your
attitude and attitude is determined by
your atmosphere always put yourself in
the sphere where you have a chance to
succeed put yourself in the presence of
people who think like you want to get
like you and illegible so not only am i
encourage you to use phrase of as a
basis of encouragement but to be an
encouragement but to hang around with
people who do that and when you deal
with your people and you bring a new one
in it's their success you need and then
you get rewards that's why people want
to take a lot of money out of the sales
kit and it's against the law
first of all to do that as part of our
settlement with the government here that
we would not put money in the sales kit
as a profit so there's no profit in the
act of recruiting the profit comes when
you help that person succeed that's a
vital foundation principle help others
first and then you succeed a long time
since I told stories about my boat but
Jay and I bought a schooner the schooner
Elizabeth and this was the bell off from
it and it's only important because the
boat sank she was kind of a nice little
boat but she leaked a lot it was our
first big sailing experiences but we
bought it we went on and we sank and
have all in many volt since then you
learn from mistakes you guys start with
faith and belief in yourself without
something you better make it your
business to do it's from the heart that
we derive our emotions and our energy to
take on and meet new challenges this is
a business where your heart has to be in
it and you have to believe that you can
do it and overcome the resistance and
the negative influence of others to move
forward so have a good heart for this
business and find out what you can do
most all of you will discover you can do
things you never thought you could do
you can advance farther than you ever
thought you could advance once you put
your heart into believing that you can
do that
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Chris Westcott
asked me to so there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it down the comments below
and I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know what is rich
things that had the biggest impact on
you what are you going to take from this
video and immediately apply to your life
your business somehow leave it down in
the comments below and I'm going to join
in the discussion finally I want to give
a quick shout out to bite-sized lessons
by mr. moe thank you so much for picking
up a copy of my book your one word and
making that awesome cartoon and posting
it to your Instagram page I really
really really appreciate it and hope
you're enjoying the book so thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon
you but keep it on here on that's all
there's always tough periods in any
business in any life at any time and
that doesn't mean anything except you
got to work your way around and work
your way through it it doesn't say you
review your plans figure out what you
might have done right or different and
then get on with it everybody quit when
things were not quite favorable well
then nobody would get anywhere but if
you want to get somewhere the best time
is when it's bad so that well everybody
else is crying you're working and you
build it up thank you very much first of
all